>>> WE'RE FOLLOWING BREAKING
NEWS ON THE JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION.
THE FULL HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES VOTING JUST A
LITTLE WHILE AGO TO HOLD FORMER
TRUMP ADVISER, STEVE BANNON, IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
LET'S GO TO RYAN NOBLES.
HE'S UP ON CAPITOL HILL.
THE HOUSE JUST SENT THE CRIMINAL
REFERRAL LETTER ON BANNON TO THE
U.S. JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, WOLF.
NANCY PELOSI JOINED BY THE CHAIR
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ASSIGNED
THAT CRIMINAL CONTEMPT REFERRAL
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY AFTER IT WAS
PASSED BE I THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
WE WERE TOLD THE CLERK HAD IT IN
THE HANDS OF THE U.S. ATTORNEY
IN WASHINGTON, D.C. BY 5:30 THIS
AFTERNOON.
THIS AS THE SELECT COMMITTEE
CONTINUES ITS QUICK WORK TO GET
THE INFORMATION THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR.
STEVE BANNON, A LONG TIME
ADVISER, FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THE MAN WHO PREDICTED THIS
ON THE DAY BEFORE JANUARY 6th --
>> ALL HELL IS GOING TO BREAK
LOOSE TOMORROW.
>> IS NOW IN A LEGAL
PREDICAMENT.
>> THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
>> THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
VOTING TO REFER HIM TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS
BECAUSE HE HAS REFUSED TO COMPLY
WITH A SUBPOENA OF THE JANUARY
6th SELECT COMMITTEE.
>> IF YOU ACT DELIBERATELY WITH
SNEERING, CAVALIER CONTEMPT FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES, WE WILL HOLD
YOU IN CONTEMPT.
WE WILL GET TO THE TRUTH OF THE
VIOLENT ASSAULT ON AMERICA.
DO NOT BELIEVE FOR ONE MOMENT
THAT IF WE FAIL TO HOLD STEVE
BANNON ACCOUNTABLE THAT HE WILL
BE THE EXCEPTION.
HE WILL BECOME THE RULE.
NOT A RULE OF LAW.
BUT THE MISRULE OF MEN.
EITHER WE ARE ALL EQUAL BEFORE
THE LAW OR NONE OF US IS.
THIS IS THE ESSENCE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> NINE REPUBLICANS JOINED
DEMOCRATS IN THE CONTEMPT VOTE.
ONE OF THEM, LIZ CHENEY,
CRITICIZING HER OWN PARTY.
>> IN THIS CHAMBER RIGHT NOW WHO
WERE EVACUATED WITH ME AND WITH
THE REST OF US ON THAT DAY
DURING THAT ATTACK.
PEOPLE WHO NOW SEEM TO HAVE
FORGOTTEN THE DANGER OF THE
MOMENT, THE ASSAULT ON THE
CONSTITUTION, THE ASSAULT ON OUR
CONGRESS.
>> THE VOTE NOW TRIGGERS A
PROCESS IN THE HANDS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THEY WILL DECIDE IF BANNON'S
DEFIANCE IS WORTHY OF
PROSECUTION.
IF CONVICTED, HE COULD FACE
FINES AND JAIL TIME.
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND WILL
HAVE THE FINAL CALL.
>> DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL DO
WHAT IT ALWAYS DOES IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WILL APPLY THE FACTS IN THE LAW
TO MAKE A DECISION.
>> MEANWHILE, THE COMMITTEE
CONTINUES TO NEGOTIATE WITH
OTHER TRUMP ALLIES TO GET THEM
TO COOPERATE WITH THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
THEY'VE POSTPONED DEPOSITIONS
FOR MARK MEADOWS AND PENTAGON
OFFICIAL, KASH PATEL.
DAN SCAVINO IS NOW SCHEDULED TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE ON
NOVEMBER 4th AS SOME LAWMAKERS
SOUND THE ALARM ABOUT FUTURE
ELECTIONS.
>> EVEN NOW, HOWEVER, THE
EX-PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES
CONTINUE TO CAST DOUBT ON THE
LAST ELECTION AND APPEAR TO BE
DRAFTING A PLAN TO OVERTURN THE
NEXT ONE.
AND NEXT TIME, WE MAY NOT BE SO
LUCKY.
>> ALL THIS WHILE TRUMP HIMSELF
CONTINUES TO PEDAL FALSE
RHETORIC ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION
IN ATTEMPTS TO WHITEWASH THE
VIOLENCE AND CHAOS OF JANUARY
6th.
THE INSURRECTION TOOK PLACE ON
NOVEMBER 3rd, TRUMP WROTE IN A
STATEMENT.
JANUARY 6th WAS A PROTEST.
>> AND WHILE THE COMMITTEE DOES
WANT TO GET AS MUCH INFORMATION
AS THEY CAN FROM STEVE BANNON,
THEY ARE ALSO USING TODAY'S VOTE
AS A SIGNAL TO THE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT THEY'VE SUBPOENAED THAT
THEY WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
TO GET THAT INFORMATION.
THEY'RE STILL NEGOTIATING WITH
MARK MEADOWS AND KASH PATEL.
THEY'RE HOPING TO HEAR FROM DAN
SCAVINO THE FIRST WEEK IN
NOVEMBER.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH A KEY MEMBER
OF THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE, ADAM
SCHIFF.
ALSO THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND HE'S
THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW BEST
SELLER, MIDNIGHT IN WASHINGTON,
HOW WE ALMOST LOST OUR DEMOCRACY
AND STILL COULD.
CONGRESSMAN, WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE
TO THE VAST MAJORITY OF YOUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WHO VOTED
AGAINST HOLDING STEVE BANNON IN
CONTEMPT?
>> WELL, IF THEY THINK THEY CAN
DO A CARVE OUT HERE AND
ESSENTIALLY EXEMPT ONE OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S FRIENDS
WITHOUT E VIS RATING CONGRESS'
POWER, THEY'RE WRONG.
WHETHER WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TAILGATE OR WE LOSE OUT ON A
FUNDAMENTAL ASPECT OF OUR
DEMOCRACY THAT THE RULE OF LAW
APPLIES TO EVERYONE AND NO ONE
IS ABOVE THAT LAW.
SO THEY'RE UNDERMINING THEIR OWN
INSTITUTION.
A SYSTEM OF CHECKS AND BALANCES,
AND THEY'RE CONTINUING TO DAMAGE
THAT THEY DID IN PUSHING THE BIG
LIE ABOUT THE ELECTION.
>> REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN, JIM
BANKS, SCOFFED AT THE IDEA THAT
STEVE BANNON HAD ADVANCED
KNOWLEDGE SAYING, QUOTING, EVERY
AMERICAN KNEW THAT VIOLENCE WAS
A POSSIBILITY THAT DAY.
WHAT'S YOUR REACT TO THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IF STEVE BANNON
HAS NOTHING TO SAY AND NOTHING
TO FEAR THEN WHY IS HE
OBSTRUCTING CONGRESS AND
REFUSING TO TESTIFY?
SO LET'S FIND OUT WHAT HE KNOWS.
CLEARLY, HE HAD A REASON TO SAY
HE THOUGHT ALL HELL WAS GOING TO
BREAK LOOSE, AND IT DID.
HE WAS IN COMMUNICATION WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HE MAY KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT WHO
ORGANIZED THESE RALLIES, WHAT
THE PARTICIPATION WAS GOING TO
BE AMONG THESE WHITE
NATIONALISTS GROUPS.
THERE'S ONE WAY TO FIND OUT AND
THAT'S TO PUT HIM UNDER OATH AT
THIS POINT.
IF HE DOESN'T, I HOPE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL PUT HIM
IN JAIL.
>> SPEAKING OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND TESTIFIED TODAY THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL APPLY
THE FACTS AND THE LAW, HIS
WORDS, TO CONSIDER YOUR REFERRAL
TO HOLD BANNON IN CONTEMPT.
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DECLINES TO PROSECUTE HIM, WHAT
WOULD THAT, WHERE WOULD THAT
LEAVE YOUR OVERALL
INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, I THINK IT WOULD BE A
REAL BODY BLOW.
IF THEY DO APPLY THE FACTS TO
THE LAW, I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
QUITE SIMPLE.
BECAUSE STEVE BANNON HAS NO
IMMUNITY TO SOMEHOW JUST FAIL TO
SHOW UP.
I THINK NO VALID PRIVILEGE CLAIM
TO ASSERT AND EVEN IF HE DID, HE
WOULD NEED TO COME BEFORE THE
CONGRESS AND SPECIFY WHICH
QUESTION, WHICH DOCUMENT, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WAS FORMALLY
ASSERTING PRIVILEGE.
NONE OF THAT HAPPENED.
SO THE FACTS COULD BE CLEAR.
THE LAW ALSO COULD BE CLEAR.
AND TO ME, THIS IS AN EARLY TEST
OF WHETHER OUR DEMOCRACY IS
RECOVERING.
IN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SHRUGS
AND SAYS WE'RE NOT GOING
FORWARD, THEY'RE INVITING OTHER
CONTEMPT OF LAW BY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS.
NOT JUST CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS,
BUT CONTEMPT OF THE LAW MORE
GENERALLY.
AND I JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHERE THE GARLAND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WANTS TO GO.
>> HOW SOON WILL YOUR SELECT
COMMITTEE DECIDE WHETHER TO
PURSUE CONTEMPT FOR OTHER
WITNESSES?
FOR EXAMPLE, MARK MEADOWS AND
DAN SCAVINO, AND KASH PATEL?
>> AS SOON AS WE DECIDE WE'RE
GET
GETTING NOWHERE.
IF WE FEEL LIKE WE'RE GETTING
STALLED FOR TIME, WE WON'T
HESITATE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
CONTEMPT.
BUT IF WE CAN WORK IT OUT AND
SECURE THEIR TESTIMONY WITHOUT
HAVING TO BRING UP